Hello.
>> Yeah. Hello.
>> Hi. How are you?
>> I'm all right. How are you? Okay.
>> I'm all right. Um, so I'm a current
Christian and I was just wondering what
are some uh as a revert. Yeah. I've been
thinking about converting for a while.
>> Someone is there someone speaking to
you? Is it?
>> Uh, there's someone else here. Yes.
But yeah, I have a question um
>> about becoming a Muslim as a Christian.
I've been a Christian my whole life
basically and
>> yeah and I've been uh learning more
about the Quran and I've been reading it
trying to understand it and I've been
trying to understand the monotheism you
know how there's the holy trinity
trinity with Christianity.
>> Yeah. I've been trying to understand
that as well but I've been having issues
with that. So I was just wondering if
you could explain to me um the
monotheism
in Quran in the Quran.
>> You know uh the Quran monism in the
Quran is clear that Allah subhana ta
based upon his mercy and his justice and
his wisdom he sent the prophets and
messengers. He chose people amongst us
to convey his message and to call people
to worship one god. And these god
possess beautiful names and lovely
attributes. In Islam, we believe the
prophets and messengers came to teach us
about worshiping Allah alone. What what
does it mean worship? Meaning when you
pray, you pray to Allah alone. When you
supplicate, you supplicate to Allah
alone. When you sacrifice animal, you do
it for the sake of God. So any act of
worship has to be directed to Allah. We
don't pray to prophet Muhammad. We don't
pray to prophet Jesus. We don't pray to
prophet Moses. We pray to Allah
directly. However, prophet Moses,
Prophet Jesus, Prophet Muhammad
wasallam came to teach us how to worship
Allah. Allah in the Quran mentioned
clearly.
They have not been commanded except to
worship Allah sincerely. And likewise
Allahh mentioned the Quran
we have sent a messenger to every nation
proclaiming worship Allah alone and stay
away from the false gods. Likewise,
Allah mentioned
we have an message except one there's
another verse I was going to mention
which Allahh said
the message is that we every messenger
we sent we send it to call people to
worship Allah alone. The point here is
all the prophets and messengers came to
call us to monism and as I have
mentioned montheism
in Islam mean to single out Allah in his
action mean there's no one to be
independent creator except Allah.
There's no one that provide for the
creation except Allah. No one can cause
people to die bring dead people back to
life except Allah. And likewise when you
pray you pray to Allah alone. Likewise,
you affirm Allah's names and attributes
the way befit his majesty. This is the
meaning of monism according to the
Quranic and the prophetic Muhammad
teaching.
As for Christianity, I do agree with
you. You no one can understand trinity,
sister.
>> Yeah, that's right. It's hard to
understand that.
>> My wife is a revert, by the way, and I
mentioned that many times.
>> Yeah,
>> that's beautiful. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So
my wife my wife one thing she said she
could not comprehend it and grasp
trinity concepts because even you have
people to pray to Mary you know like you
know how God become a baby God is
perfect you know that's why even in the
Bible there's no clearcut passage Jesus
said I am God and the father is God and
the holy spirit is god all of us we are
three god in one all of this teaching
came later on by the Roman pagans is not
by Jesus. Jesus clearly said, "Oh
children of Israel, our God is one God."
Not three is one God.
Understand?
>> Yes, I do understand.
>> Why are you are you born again? Like
were you born again or Catholic?
>> Um uh Pentecostal.
>> Pentecostal. Yeah. Okay. So yeah.
Alhamdulillah. I mean Islam, what you
have to understand sister is
Christianity is a madeup religion that
was invented even the term Christianity
was invented by Paul. If you look to the
Bible Jesus never called himself a
Christian. We say Jesus was a Muslim.
What do you mean by by that? Jesus said
I can't do nothing by myself. He submit
to God. Islam is Arabic terminology. If
you translate into English means to
submit to God or to submit your will to
God according to God's teaching.
>> Likewise Moses, the word Judaism is not
in the Old Testament. And Moses never
call himself I have Judaism religion or
I'm a Jewish religion. That's their
background. But Moses, Abraham, Noah,
Jacob, Isaac, Daniel, Jeremiah, Ishmael,
all of them submit themselves to God.
That's why in the Quran, Allah said all
of them, all the prophets and messengers
were Muslims. Meaning they submit
themselves to God alone. And Islam
sister when you become Muslim, you have
direct relationship with Allah. You
don't have to go through no one to call
upon Allah. If you have problem, you
just raise your hand to Allah or you
make abolution and you pray to Allah.
Jesus pray to God and we pray to God.
Christians pray to Jesus.
Jesus pray to God.
>> Correct.
>> That's correct.
>> Okay. The Christians they pray to Jesus.
We Muslims we pray to God. So we are
like Jesus. We pray to God directly.
>> Oh, hence the one.
>> Yes.
>> Yes. Of course, this the oneness and
this is the most important aspect of uh
uh religion. Like even in the in the Old
Testament, the first commandment is to
worship God alone and to love him with
all your hearts. That's the first
commandment.
>> You understand?
>> Yes. Understood. Uh how about with your
wife? You know how you said she's a
revert?
>> Yeah.
>> Uh how did she get over the doubts? You
know how you have to learn? It's like
learning new stuff again as in
>> you know the the analogy that I give my
sister you know imagine you have a big
cake in front of you big nice sweet cake
if you eat all of it at once what will
happen you get sick you will vomit okay
>> in order for you to feel the sweetness
of the cake what you do you take it bit
by bit correct
>> yes
>> likewise when you come to Islam the most
important thing learn is the the attain
the two testimonies. Then slowly slowly
start learning you know so slowly slowly
and uh alhamdulillah my wife she was
learning slowly slowly of course even
when look the the wife of the prophet
Muhammadatam
our mother is she said the first thing
Allah revealed to his prophet inspired
his prophet with is about monism is
about describing paradise describing the
hellfire describing the outcome come of
those who believe in God and follow his
teaching and describing the outcome of
those who rejected God and opposes his
teaching. Later on, Allah sent down
obligations like prayer, fasting. So
even when prophet Muhammad came to the
people, he never came with everything at
once. Even me myself, you know, I'm not
perfect, you know, and you know, I have
my shortcomings. So but I try my best.
So don't let the shaitan my sister try
to prevent you from becoming a Muslim
because of you have to learn new things.
Noah you will learn. I mean like
alhamdulillah my wife now mashallah she
learns a lot of things. Mashallah you
understand you will learn but slowly
slowly and step by step.
>> That's right. Another question. How do I
become certain about accepting Islam?
>> I'll tell you how you become certain.
You know uh for example I'll give you
some uh proofs why Islam is a truth to
increase your certainty and to make to
understand why Islam is a truth. You
know what distinguish Islam from any way
of life or any religion. Islam is not
based upon dreams. Meaning I don't
believe Islam is the truth because I had
a dream or because um because of my
personal experience. I'm not going to
tell you sister become a Muslim because
you know I in prison and when I was in
prison I prayed to God to Allah and
Allah saved me and this and that. This
is from my personal experience. Islam is
a truth because it's based upon
universal proofs. For example, now we
look to the Quran. The Quran within it
Allah challenge people to bring
something of the Quran. So Allah
mentioned in the Quran the meaning of
the verse that if you are in doubt about
the prophet Muhammad and that which he
came with then bring something like it
like the Quran in its eloquency
legislation in its prophecies also in
the Quran Allah mentioned
we have made Quran easy to be memorized
so it's illogical irrational impossible
for someone to live 1,400 years ago to
tell you my book, it will be memorized
by 100 million of people. Now, if you go
to Africa, you go to Asia, to Europe, to
America, to Australia and other places,
you will find many Muslims memorize the
Quran word for word, letter for letter.
And what is very interesting about this,
sometimes those who memorize the Quran,
they don't even speak Arabic.
They don't even speak Arabic. Imagine.
Imagine all of us we we memorize this
book in Chinese. Imagine all of us here
in the chat room we memorize book in
Chinese. But guess what? We don't even
speak Chinese.
>> Yeah.
>> It's is a miracle how how you memorize a
book in a language and you don't even
speak it.
>> That's right.
>> You with me? Also in the Quran, Allah
said
we have sent down the Quran and we will
preserve it. Now if the Muslims and the
Christians and Jewish all of them came
together and they decided to burn their
scriptures say you know what let's get
rid of our scriptures the only scripture
will remain with us is the Quran because
the Quran is in our hearts is you know
you know who can bring it back into the
written form not the Muslim scholars
even though the Muslim scholars memorize
the Quran but the Muslim children
because they memorize the Quran And you
know, so so so how a man that existed
1,400
years ago coming with a book and is
telling you that this book is easy to be
memorized
not just for Arabs, even for the
non-Arabs. And likewise, this book will
be preserved.
And for example, when it come to the
Bible, the Bible, we don't have it in
its original language, but the Quran we
still have in Arabic language. Likewise
in the Quran, Allah mentioned, you know,
about LGBTQ.
>> Yes.
>> Allah spoke about them in the Quran.
>> You know how in the Quran Allah
mentioned that Allah said Satan will
inspire people to change Allah's
creation.
Does Allah Allah mentioned that Satan
will inspire to to change Allah Allah's
creation. Now many people are born like
a man healthy and everything because
they feel like a woman. What they do?
They go and have an operation to change
their their physical appearance. You
know likewise in the Quran Allah said
it is Allah who sent Prophet Muhammad
Islam in order for Islam to prevail all
the other religions. Now, even though
there is a huge war against Islam by the
mainstream media try to make Islam look
bad, the fastest growing religion on the
face of the earth is Islam. Who's doing
the job? The most high Allah.
>> Likewise, that's sorry.
>> Oh, I said God himself. Yes, you're
right. Of course, you know, when you
look at the Muslim countries, if you
compare the Muslim countries to
non-Muslim countries, Muslim countries
are weak in terms of uh uh weapons and
and and and and
social media and so on. But the fastest
growing illusion on the face of the
earth is Islam. Why? Because Islam it
goes in line with our sound reasoning,
with our sound intellect, likewise with
our sound natural inclination, you know.
So also I was going to mention prophet
Muhammad
said in a hadith he said there will come
a time you know about interest.
>> Mhm.
>> You know interest. Yeah.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> Yes. Prophet Muhammad wasallam said will
come a time when interest will become
widespread. Even if you are not involved
directly will still affect you. Now if
you open a bank account you know they
will use your money for interest. Even
if you tell them I don't want interest,
they will still use your money for
interest. So the question they should
ask yourself, how a man, which I'm
referring to the prophet Muhammad
that existed 1,400 years ago
prophesizing about something, we can see
it right now because that man was sent
by God and no one knows the future in
detail except who?
>> God.
>> Except God. But God sometimes he will
tell some of his prophets and messengers
about some of the events that will occur
in the future. All right? And I give you
another one. For example, now Prophet
Muhammadat wasam he said will come a
time when you see the barefoot Arab man
competing in building tall buildings.
During the life of the prophet Muhammad
wasallam, the Arabs were not known to
build tall buildings. Now let me ask you
where is the tallest building in the
world?
>> Dubai.
>> Dubai. See Dubai 50 years ago was a pure
desert. Also prophet Muhammad wasallam
said the hour the day of judgment will
never be established until the Arab Arab
peninsula will become full of river and
green.
No look at it. Go to Dubai. Go to Saudi.
>> Yeah, the prophecies were right.
>> Yeah, of course. Prophet Muhammad
prophesized many many things. For
example, I will give you another one.
Prophet Muhammad wasam, he said about
his own companions. He said you will
take over the Persian Empire and the
Roman Empire. And you have to understand
that Prophet Muhammad wasallam was from
Mecca. Mecca was in the middle of
nowhere, the middle of desert. They
didn't even have a proper army. They
were like tribes. And the Persian and
the Roman empires, the Persian and the
Roman empires, they had a big army, very
strong army. But Prophet Muhammad
wasallam when he was in Mecca, in Mecca,
he was oppressed. He was scared for his
own life. And he told his companions,
you will take over the Persians and the
Romans. Historically speaking, the
Muslims took over the Persian Empire and
the Roman Empire. Again, how how he knew
that? Because that was from Allah.
Uh are you familiar with the Old
Testament?
>> Yes, I am. Yes.
>> Do you know about you know about Isaiah
42?
>> Uh uh what's the story about?
>> Okay, one second. I'll show you
something. Okay.
>> All right. This is the This is the Bible
here. Okay. This is King James.
>> Yeah,
>> I'm gonna go. If you if you have it with
you, it's okay. But if you don't, I
will. Isaiah 42, it speaks about a man
that is coming to glorify the Lord. All
right?
>> It speaks about a man that is coming to
glorify the Lord.
Yeah. So it says here the servant comes
to glorify the Lord. Isaiah 42 one
behold my servant whom I uphold my elect
one in whom my soul delight I have put
my spirit upon him. Spirit here means a
revelation because the revelation of God
is a spirit for our lives. It's like
it's like a soul because that person the
world doesn't know doesn't know God. If
you are alive and you do not worship God
correctly, you're like a dead person. So
the the real meaning of someone alive is
a person who knows his God and he
worship his God and he follow his God's
teaching. That's the real meaning of
true life. All right.
>> Yeah.
>> And he says here he will bring forth
justice to the Gentiles. Who are the
Gentiles according to the Bible?
>> Uh the many nations
>> except the Jews. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Anyone who's not a Jewish is a
Gentile. Okay. So this prophet is coming
for to bring justice to the Gentiles.
Okay.
>> And he says here I want to mention the
main points in 11. He said let the
witness cities lift up their ways. The
village that Keda inhabits. Who is Keda?
Keda. If you go to Genesis 25:13,
Keda is a son of Ishmael. And the
prophet Muhammad he's an I ishelite.
Okay. And also he says let the inhabit
of Silah sing it. Let them shout from
the top of the mountains. Let them give
glory to the Lord. Silah is a mountain
in Saudi in Medina. So this prophecy
clearly speaking about the prophet
Muhammad. He cannot fit Jesus because
the Christians believe Jesus was God and
Jesus never came to the Gentiles. He
came for the Israelites as we mentioned
in the Bible. When the Canonite woman
followed him, he said, "I've only been
sent to the lost house sheep of Israel."
All right? And here he mentions about
the people of Keda. The people of Keda
are the offspring of Ishmael.
All right? The son of Ishmael. And
Prophet Muhammad is I is Ishelites. So
again how the book that existed
thousands of years before prophet
Muhammad prophesizing about prophet
Muhammad and it is in the Quran Allah
told us that prophet Muhammad's
description is been prophesized by the
prophets before him. So all of this
sister, his prophecies, the miracle of
the Quran, it gives you certainty why
Islam is a truth because it's illogical
irrational like I said for someone to
exist 1,400 years ago and you just told
me no one knows the future in detail
except God.
>> Yes.
>> Also sister, you know, there is a proper
uh like there is agenda and a war
against our human nature. The only
religion that is standing firm and is
not shaking against this evil secretive
uh uh societies and organization is
Islam.
And I'll tell you something what
distinguish Islam from Christianity and
other religion. Islam listen carefully
to this. Yeah. Islam came to preserve
five things. Islam came to preserve five
things. Islam came to preserve religion.
That's why in Islam we not allowed to
pray to anyone else. We only allowed to
pray to Allah alone. That's why in Islam
we're not allowed to do innovation.
Innovation mean to add things into
Islam. Okay. Uh Islam also came to
preserve the intellect. That's why
alcohol alcohol and drugs is forbidden.
Islam came to protect wealth. That's why
interest and gambling is forbidden.
Islam came to preserve lineage.
Okay? That's why fornication and
adultery is forbidden.
Allah Islam came to preserve life.
That's why killing people unjustly,
committing suicide is forbidden. These
five things that Islam came to protect
and not just to protect also to put
barriers in between h these five things.
And anyone try to break these five
things? The opposite. Let me ask you,
alcohol and drugs, is it good for us or
bad for us?
>> Very very bad for us.
>> It's bad for us individually and
collectively. Gambling, is it bad for us
or good for us?
>> Bad. Yeah.
>> Bad individually and collectively. Okay.
Likewise, what they call it uh uh uh uh
fornication and adultery is bad for us.
Fornication, adultery, people have
children and they will leave them and
you know they have the children have no
right over the parents because you know
there's no proof to prove they are the
children you know. Okay. And also uh
what they call committing suicide and
all of this and the most evil thing is
associating partners with God. All of
this evil is the outcome we send away
from God. So Islam is good for us
individually and collectively. The
question now is how come there is some
people who does not like Islam. There's
two tough people who hate Islam. either
that are ignorant who have been
brainwashed or those who are in
authority. Those who are in authority
majority of times they make money from
gambling, from interest, from what they
call it uh alcohol and so on. So they
look at Islam as a threat for their own
business. That's why they will utilize
their money to make Islam look bad even
though Islam is good for us individually
and collectively. The question how a man
that existed 1,400 years ago wasam who
couldn't read and write he came with is
a perfect way of life. What do you think
was said so far? Does it make sense?
>> Yeah, it definitely does make sense. Uh
I have another question as well. So you
know how you say
>> I might now reconsider.
>> Go ahead. Um yeah, I was going to ask um
you know how you said how Islam came to
preserve life, right?
>> Um so I have doubts in accepting the
fact that God gives the right to humans,
you know, to kill people.
>> Is that okay?
>> Should that be justified?
>> Say again.
>> Uh should that be justified? Let's say
someone wrongs you.
>> Yeah. I've heard that um God gives the
right to people you know to kill them.
Is that not just any wronging no now in
Islam uh protecting the life is very
important. However, we have to be honest
and we have to be realistic. We living
in a life that some people if they try
to kill you and the only way to stop
them from killing you by killing them
then Islam Allah give you a right
otherwise Islam is going to send a
religion of nonsense because how God
knows there's evil in this life
>> because if if even even like now for
example I can give you best example
about uh terrorist organizations which
the many countries try to speak to them
try to reason with them but they don't
want to stop. They kept killing people
and and harming people. Then of course
in Islam Allah gave the right to anal
those who does not respect lives because
if you do not respect yourself you not
respecting people's lives and you are
harming people by killing them and
causing mischief then Islam comes in.
Okay. So watch this. That's why Islam
makes sense. Okay. A person must say
taking someone's life is evil. But which
one is worse? For to take his life or
for this person to take too many lives.
>> Oh yeah.
>> So even if going to even if killing him
the apparent is evil but we're going to
cause lesser evil to remove the greater
evil
or not evil. Sorry. Sorry. We're going
to cause lesser harm to remove the
greater harm. So a lesser h by killing
one person the greater harm this person
go around and will kill many many
people.
>> But shouldn't you leave that in God's
hands?
>> You know to give it to you.
>> Sorry.
>> God you should you should leave it into
God's hands. So God put that
legislation.
>> Understand?
>> Yes. And sisters what when you saying
that um okay you don't think this or
that about God what is your criteria you
are utilizing what is the yard stick
>> I believe in Christianity because that's
been the real age I was born into so
that's what I
>> sorry in the Bible God said to kill
apostate in the Bible
in the Bible I'm not sure if you know
about the Bible Bible that if you get
married, are you married by the way?
>> Oh no, I'm not married.
>> Okay. Inshallah, you get married and you
have good husband, take care of you.
According to the Bible, if your husband
get into fight and you try to save him
because you can see this person is about
to kill your husband. So you go and hit
the person his private part according to
the Bible's teaching, your hand should
be cut off.
>> That's in the Bible here. is then I
believe in the trinity.
>> I believe it's something about when
someone slaps you on one cheek, you give
them the other one.
>> But sister in reality, no one does that.
I mean I mean there's no Christian look
at the Christians. What country you from
originally if you don't if you don't
mind me asking?
>> Uh Zimbabwe.
>> Okay. You're from Africa like me. I'm
from Algeria. The Christians came to
Africa and they they never tend their
chick. Rather they came and and beat us
up with an with a weapons and forced us
my the French came and occupied my
country for 132 years my sister for 132
years and they sent our mosque into
churches and they forced Christianity on
people and they killed many people not
just in in Algeria other countries you
understand so that's why someone
slapping one cheek give him the other
cheek so are you saying that to me if
Someone now come to my house and try to
to rape my sister. I will bring in my
wife as well.
>> Oh no, definitely not.
>> What should I do?
>> Protect your wife. Your sister.
>> How can I protect my sister? By killing
him.
>> I have to fight.
>> You have to fight back.
>> Defend them. Of course. Yeah.
>> Of course. That's why sister Islam, like
I said, Islam goes in line with the
sound intellect. This teacher of some if
someone Yes. In Islam Allah teach you
forgive. Okay. If you forgive is much
better. Yes. But there certain things
you cannot forgive. Like someone come to
rape my wife or my sister. I'm going to
do everything to protect my family.
>> That's right.
>> You understand? But forgiving is very uh
it's very Allah recommend us to forgive
and overlook you know and help people.
You understand? But for every situation
there is a way to deal with it. It is
from foolishness and at time of
harshness you be soft. Likewise it's
from foolishness in a time of softness
you be harsh.
>> That's right. Yes. Yes. Yes. Um
>> you agree?
>> I agree.
>> The wise man the wise man put everything
in its proper places at the right time.
>> Yeah. Yeah. How about the issue with
modesty? Um, was your wife in is she a
nikabi hijabi?
>> Yes.
>> When she became Muslim, she start wear
then she start wear alhamdulillah.
>> That's beautiful. Yeah.
>> And she become Muslim. May Allah
preserve and protect her.
My wife, she become Muslim when she was
14.
>> Oh wow. That's even better.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Now she's been Muslim
for many years. Alhamdulillah.
>> So how do you get over these doubts? You
know, for instance, in public, you might
feel as if, oh, I don't fit in when you
become a revert and then you start
dressing up a certain way. For instance,
wearing a hijab. How do you accept that,
you know, without any doubts at all?
>> Yes. But again, sister, you're not here
to please people regardless what you're
going to do. I'll tell you a story. It's
a funny story. They said there was a man
with his son and they had a donkey. So
they they walked past a group of people.
So the people said, "Look at these two
people. They have a donkey and they
don't they don't not use it." Then the
the father said to his son or my son, me
and you, let us ride on a donkey. So
they walked past by another group of
people. The other group of people said,
"Look at these two people. They are
making a hard on a donkey." both of them
on a donkey. So the father said, "Oh my
son, you you get off. Let me just me
stay on a donkey." So they walked past,
but another group of people.
So the the other group of people said,
"Look at this man. He's a strong and
he's letting his own son walk while he's
on a donkey." So he said, "Oh my oh my
son, let me get off. You come and ride
on a donkey." So the father got off and
he got his son to sit on a donkey. Then
they walked past by another group of
people. They said, "Look at this young
boy. He's on a donkey while his father
is walking." So he said, "Oh my son, you
and I let us carry a donkey." So
regardless what you do, you never be
pleased. You never be able to please
people. Always people say something bad
about you. But you are here to please
Allah, the creator of everything. So you
have to what do you call it to not make
your your main concern is pleasing
people. Yes, be good to them. Try to be
nice to people and so on. But
alhamdulillah like you know me myself I
I wear you know this Islamic garments
you know I wear it. Alhamdulillah. So
hijab alhamdulillah especially now
sister in London you're from London.
>> I'm not Australia.
>> Okay. I don't know about Australia but
even Australia I believe so Islam like
there's a lot of Muslims. So you know
just wear the Islamic government.
Alhamdulillah
Allah you know. Alhamdulillah sister
look they can't tell you nothing. Now in
Europe in the western world now we have
people believe they are animals
and they're dressed like animals and
they don't say nothing about them. You
covering yourself and Australia supposed
to be a Christian country so you're
going to dress like Mary. Mary she
covered herself.
>> Yeah she did.
>> See
>> yeah so you'll be dressing like Mary.
You know, you know, so the pro but we
live in a time very strange when a woman
she wants to dress modestly, people look
down on her. You see how everything and
and the prophet Muhammad told us about
this. He said will come a time when the
truthful will behold as a liar and when
a when a liar will behold as a truthful
and you know one thing I don't know but
you know one thing that helped me to
stay firm upon Islam and practicing that
before I started practicing I was doing
crazy things and I was never shy I was
just doing anything so I said to myself
how can I be shy about my religion how
can I be shy about something that please
Allah but before when I was pleasing
shan I was not shy.
>> Yeah.
See, so alhamdulillah you know like I
said of course everything slowly slowly
step by step that the most important
thing is
the two testimonies which is
as a Christian you add
which means I bear witness there's
nothing worthy of worship in truth
except Allah and I bear witness Muhammad
is the last messenger and the servant
Allah and I bear witness that Jesus is
the servant and the messenger of Allah.
And I want to tell you something about
uh Christianity and Islam. You know, of
course, there's certain things we
believe the same like I believe Jesus
was born without a father and he was
born and he was the Messiah. Okay? And
he he had the miracles of bringing dead
people back to life. But one thing I was
going to mention,
the story of Mary, when you read the
story of Mary in the Bible and you
compare it to the Quranic story, the
Quranic story is more logical rule. When
we read the Bible, the story in the
Bible in the New Testament that Mary got
pregnant
and according to the Mosaic law, the
rabbis should ston Mary to death because
she fall of course she get she got
pregnant and she has no husband or
partner. Okay. So, and now according to
the Bible for God to save her, the Holy
Spirit came to Joseph the carpenter and
told him to marry her. Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> But everyone knew that was not his
father.
>> So, but the Quranic story, watch this.
Let me give you an example. I like to
give analogy to make something to make
things clearer. Imagine you have a
daughter and she comes to you and she
says, "Mommy, I'm pregnant."
Okay? Or she brings a child and tell you
this is my son. It's like 5 months, 6
months. And you tell her, "Do you have a
husband?" No. No.
>> Do you have a partner? No.
>> So, how do you have a child? God gave it
to me. Would you believe her?
>> Yeah. Not at all.
>> Not at all. You think what? Do you think
I'm crazy? You don't believe? But she
would say, "Okay, I will prove to you
that God gave it to me. The baby that is
4 months inside the cradle, he will
speak to you and he will tell you, yes,
she's my mother." And he will and he
will start speaking. Now it's more
likely you believe her.
>> Yeah.
>> Because it's a miracle how a baby in
that inside the cradle is speaking. And
this is how Allah defended the owner of
Mary Miam when she went to her people
the the Israelites and they said to her
or the sister of Aaron your father was
not an evil man and your mother she was
not a fornicator
though she point at him so she for Jesus
And Jesus start speaking to speaking to
them.
He said I am the servant Allah and this
is to free himself from the lies that
has been attributed to him that is God
or a son of God
and Allah give me a book
and make me a prophet. That's why when
they saw that they knew that Mary is
speaking the truth. You with me so far?
>> Yes. Still here.
>> Okay. Alhamdulillah. Do you have other
questions?
>> Uh yes, one last question. Uh how do I
clear the doubts of the people that
attack you know Islam and how also they
also have debates with Muslims and
Christians where they usually win and
they talk about stuff that I don't
really understand like how
>> who wins who wins?
>> Uh the
Christians like
>> what? Give me an example of a topic that
you think Christians win.
uh like for instance how prophet
Muhammad married a child from what I've
heard and how all the sex of Islam
Muslims are fighting each other and how
all these attacks you know
>> they're always attacked in different
countries that's kind of making me
harder to understand as well
>> step by step okay let's go to the
marriage of prophet Muhammad
>> you know
>> the Christians cannot really utilize it
why the Christians believe God pretend
became a baby. Okay. So we Muslims can
tell them hang on if you having a
problem for prophet Muhammad getting
married to Isa but you believe God
became a baby and he went inside woman
private part and according to the Bible
according to Christians when Jesus was
having breastfed that was God touching
Mary breast.
So if for the sake of argument if
they're going to say prophet Muhammad
what he did was wrong and evil which one
is worse I mean the worst one God
pretending to be a child why he was god
and going inside woman private part and
also god touching woman breast
you with me
>> uh yes still here
>> so so what I'm saying that if the
Christians they are able able to accept
God became a baby and he was inside
woman private part and he was God and he
was touching Mary's breast and that was
God then that brain should accept
anything
of respect
if you have if your brain is able to
accept this a nonsensical thing which
God imagine God touching a woman breast
do you accept that
>> yes I do accept it
>> but you accept that
>> no I I don't accept that at all, but
that's what I believe in. You know, it's
hard to diverge from that when you've
learned that your whole life.
>> Yeah. But what I'm saying, sister,
utilize our self intellect.
>> Yeah.
>> How God that's why I'm saying that's the
Christians, they have no leg to stand on
by saying Prophet Muhammad got married
to Also, I'm not sure if you're aware
that Joseph the Carpenter was 90 years
old when he got married to Mary. She was
12.
I didn't know that at all.
>> Of course, because this historically is
known if you go to Catholic
encyclopedia is mentioned. Also, what I
would say to you sister that when you
look back, do you know about uh
presentism? You know, it's presentism.
>> I'm not familiar with that one. No.
>> Presentism is a logical fallacy that
people use to judge people of the past
based upon our moral standard.
So will prophet let us see so prophet
Muhammad
if he was
have you ever heard pedo goes to
people's parents to ask for marriage
>> pedo doesn't go to a child to parents
say can I marry your daughter
>> I never like that in my life
>> I've never heard that either that's
right
>> yes Yeah.
>> So that's one thing. And the ped only
interested in children.
>> Yeah. They are.
>> Okay. Prophet Muhammad wasallam his
first wife she was older than him.
Second wife she was same age as him. All
his wives they were either older than
him or younger than him or same age as
him. So that that refutes the argument
of pedo. That's not the nature of pedo.
Also prophet Muhammad had enemies.
had enemies from the Romans, the
Persians, the the Arab pagans. When he
got married to Isa, how come his enemies
didn't say nothing about it?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Now, I'll give you another one.
Okay. Do you care about more than her
parents?
>> No,
>> you don't. I don't care. Her parents,
they care more about her. Okay.
Likewise, about her own tribe, about her
own people. All right. So now that say
there was no any Christian scholar or
Jewish rabbi had a problem with the
prophet Muhammad getting married to
Aisha. The first person that started
using the argument of prophet Muhammad
Muhammad getting married to Aisha was a
British orientalist in the 19th century
literally two centuries ago. So for
1,200 years the Christians and Jewish
and and the and the pagans none of them
had a problem with the prophet Muhammad
getting married to Aisha. Do you know
why?
>> Why is that?
>> Because if you study history of marriage
in Britain, France, Belgium, Africa,
Europe, America, Asia, the age of
marriage was 7 and 101.
>> What?
>> Yes. the church, the the the king of
England, the Richard II, the king of
England, he got married to Isabella, the
the the princess of France. She was 6
years old when he got married to her.
>> Yeah. Okay. And now I have a book which
she speaks breaks it down for you. What
happened before sister? There was not
like this you know now we have child
then pre-adolescence then adolescent
then teenager then pre-teenia then we
have adult then we have all these stages
was created in the 19th century. Before
that either you are a child or a man
child or woman. How they to
differentiate is by uh uh puberty.
And before are you from Africa? And I'm
from Africa. When you go to Africa due
to poverty, a lot of children they don't
go to school. What they do? They go out
and provide for their families.
So you meet a child at the age of 10,
11. The way they speak is like someone
50 years old in Britain. They provide
you with me.
>> Yeah. They're going out.
>> I can tell you kings. I'll tell you
kings that were at the age of 11 and 12
and they were kings also the the I don't
know if you know the king faiz the king
of Saudi he was 14 years old when he was
an ambassador and came to Britain you
can check it on on YouTube imagine now
14 years old ambassador of a country
>> it wouldn't make any sense yeah
>> that's what I'm saying and I can show
you listen I have my phone let me show
you let me show you understand
So
she said when a girl reached the age of
nine is a woman
king fa. Okay a second
I want to show you something to
understand.
So
okay.
All right. This is the I'm going to
Sorry, there's music, but I want to show
>> uh
>> Oh, so what you're trying to say is that
um that things are a bit different now.
Back in the day, people were more
>> That's it. Look at him. This in UK.
>> Look, look, look. He's in UK.
>> Do you see that?
>> Yep. I see that.
>> He was 14 years old. Look, look, look.
14 years old. Now if someone tell you
there is someone 14 years old and he's a
he's a ambassador of a country, would
you accept it?
>> Not at all.
>> Yeah. Things are different.
>> You understand? So now it's different.
Now we have schools, we have nursery, we
have college, university. But before
they used to get mature quicker and
sometimes based upon the the country I
mean do you know the youngest mother in
in history uh she was uh 8 years old. Do
you know what country she was from?
>> No. Where was she from?
>> Nigeria and she was a Christian.
>> Wow. Yeah.
>> Yeah. And she became and the and the the
youngest grandmother again she was 18
years old.
cuz she got married at the age of eight.
She was Africa as well. She got married
at the age of eight. Then her child got
married at the age of eight.
>> Okay. Um how far right now in Somalia
>> sister the marriage of prophet Muhammad
it was something normal. Okay. And again
you know when you look when you study
the biography of she was a scholar she
was a doctor. Okay. She was rather the
companions prophet Muhammad wasallam
used to refer back to her. Now of course
in Islam the age of marriage there is no
specific age. Why? Because Islam is for
every country and every time. For
example in Britain the age of marriage
it says 18. The Islamist say you're
allowed to have 18. Why? Because the
people are an expert. They look at the
Shabb the young people and they think
you know what at the age of 15 16
they're not mature enough to get
married. So let us raise the age 18.
Islam have no problem with that. Okay.
You go to another country say the age of
marriage is 25. Okay. So Islam leaves
the age of marriage open. However,
however with the principle do not harm
yourself and do not harm others. Is that
clear so far?
Hello.
>> Hello. Yes, that's right. That's right.
>> Okay. I mean like if from Africa study
history about Africa, you know, now
every you know what's happening, sister,
now they think the whole world is
Britain. No, the whole world is Britain.
Britain. Britain. Yes. In Islam, like I
said to you, if they believe the age of
marriage, the proper age for people to
get married 18 age, then they have that.
They allowed to have that. In some
countries, you'll get mature quicker.
All right? But guess what, sister? Have
you not noticed? They keep raising the
age of marriage by lowering the age of
having sex outside marriage.
>> M good point.
>> See,
>> so a girl and a boy can sleep around at
the age of 15, 16, but to get married,
no, no, no, no, no. They're still young.
So to do something to please God,
they're still young. But to do the same
thing, but to do it to please the Satan,
it's okay.
>> Yeah. Very much contradictory. I see.
>> You have to understand what's happening.
>> How about right now in Somalia? You know
how there was a law to ban child
marriage
>> first?
What is a child marriage? And I do agree
to there is some countries some Muslim
countries they do abuse it. Did you know
there is a scholar called he died 20
years ago he said the age of marish
should be 18 or 16 or do you know he
said that he's a scholar he's a selfie
scholar which the west call
fundamentalist scholar he said because
the the the the people now you know
changed and everything so there is some
countries like Somalia or Yemen or India
they do abuse young marriage of not
children Because the term child it
differs okay young marriage okay so in
Somalia if the country thinks you know
what people are abusing it and are
forcing their children to get married
and they raise the age of marriage Islam
have no problem with that
>> it's a cultural thing not a religious
thing basically
>> Islam does not prevent you to follow
your culture as long your culture does
not oppose Islamic teaching and cause
people to harm each other
But you know we have to understand as
well the most leading countries of child
marriage a lot of them is a Christian
country. Ethiopia is a Christian country
>> but no one speaks about it.
>> That's right. Yeah.
>> Correct.
>> Yeah. To understand that uh but again uh
uh we don't want to be uh influenced by
the propag
the propaganda of the western media.
Mhm.
>> Yeah. Um, yeah, I understand. How about
uh you know how there's different sects
in Islam
>> like Christianity?
>> Like Christianity? Yes.
>> How do you find the right one?
>> That's a good question. Firstly, what's
happening now? Prophet Muhammad, what's
happening now about sex and groups
within Islam is a proof that Prophet
Muhammad is a true prophet. How prophet
Muhammad wasallam when he was alive when
the Muslims there were only one group.
Prophet Muhammad prophesized about the
future by saying my nation will divide
into 73 sects and groups. He said all of
them deserves to be punished with the
fire except one. So they said who are
they oh messenger of Allah? He said I'm
on today and my companions. So Islam
because it's the last way of life. The
prophet Muhammad legislation is the last
way of life. So Allah preserved the
Quran. Likewise preserve the teach of
prophet Muhammad also preserve how to
understand them through the three
generations. Prophet Muhammad taught us
to follow his companions and he praised
his disciples and their students and
their students. These three generations
called
in English by his predecessors by his
predecessors. So, Prophet Muhammad
wasallam told us about the disease which
is splitting because Allah taught us to
unite. However, unite upon the truth.
The disease is splitting and the cure is
to follow Quran and Prophet Muhammad's
teaching and the way his companions
understood it.
M
>> you with me?
>> Yeah.
>> Alhamdulillah. Islam
what do they call it? Islam Quran has
been preserved. The sunnah has been
preserved. Even how to understand the
text is being preserved by the disciples
because we still have the teaching of
the disciples of the prophet Muhammad
and their students and their students.
>> Yeah, that's right.
>> Yeah. When it comes to Christianity,
sorry, that's right. When it comes to
Christianity, you cannot say the same.
Do you know why? Because the Bible
itself is corrupted. So the criteria
like now if or Sufi or what I would say
to them, do you believe you are upon the
truth? Let's go to the Quran and see if
the Quran is with me or with you or with
the other Muslim
because the scripture is still preserved
and is still valid and is still sound.
But the Bible like I said to you is
corrupted. I have two Bibles. I have
King James and ESV. You know about ESV?
>> I only know King James version.
>> But there's other ones. There's many
ESV. There's too many.
>> But I'm not talking about the
translations. I'm talking about
literally there is some passages in King
James is not in ESV or NIV.
>> Also, you and a Catholic, you have
different books. There's 80, some you
have 60. Likewise, the Ethiopian
Christians Orthodox that I believe they
have over 100 gospels.
>> So, which one is the correct one?
>> You never really know. We Muslims will
never differ concerning the text. We
differ how to understand it. But you
Christians, you differ concerning the
text itself.
>> Yeah.
>> You see the difference between us
>> too many alterations to the Bible. Yeah.
Whereas the Quran very straightforward.
It's the same message.
>> Yes.
>> Same language.
>> For example, you have the Old Testament
and the New Testament. They go and they
say in the old testament anyone that is
hanged on a tree is cursed and then you
have the the old the new testament you
believe that Jesus was was hanged on a
pole and he was crucified but in the old
testament says anyone believe that
anyone who has been hanged on a on a
cross is cursed. In the old testament if
you commit sin you should be responsible
for it. In the new testament according
to Christians Jesus died for your sins.
In the Old Testament, no one should die
for no one's sins. In the Old Testament,
God is not a man at all. According to
Christians, God, Jesus, God, and a man
at the same time. In the Old Testament,
all the prophets and the messengers were
circumcised. In the New Testament,
Christians who follow Paul, they're not
circumcised.
>> Contradictory.
>> Of course.
>> Yeah. That's why subhan Allah sister
that's why Islam is spreading that we're
in the western world we're not using no
knife no spoon no hammer nothing people
are accepting Islam by their own will
because like I said to you when you look
at Islam one of the one of the greatest
miracle of Islam as the Quran it goes in
line with the sound intellect God create
us all all of us.
So that's why there are certain things
in Christianity clearly goes against our
sound intellect. I'm not talking about
opinions.
Like for example, you see some people
have different they oppose Islam or they
say I don't like this. It's not based
upon a sound intellect. It's based upon
opinions subjective.
But Christianity, God become a man,
baby, someone breastfed him. What do
they call it? God is perfect. But Jesus
didn't know the hour. God is all
powerful. But Jesus is God and he was
scared for his life. God, let me ask
you, does God have a God?
>> Not at all. God is the almighty.
>> Jesus in the Bible said, "I'm going to
my God and your God." to my father and
your father.
>> How can he be God?
>> Which proves Yeah. Which proves he's the
son of God, not God himself.
>> Not even a son of God. this term again,
a son of God. In the Quran, Allah said,
Allah said they attribute a son to Allah
and it's not befitting for Allah to have
a son. If Allah allows the heavens and
the earth to show their feelings toward
this evil statement, then the heavens
will split us under. So to ascribe a son
to God, this from the human nature. We
are the servants of God. We are the
creation of God. This term son, it came
from the Roman pagans and also it came
from the nations before the the
Babylonians and the ancient Egyptians.
The Jewish people when they said son of
God, they mean someone is righteous.
However, it's ambiguous. So in the
Quran, Allah refuted this argument that
Jesus is a son of God because God
doesn't have no children because God is
not like the creation. It is from the
creation nature to have children to pass
on our heritage to pass on our
inheritance to pass on our lineage. That
is not the nature of the most high. The
most high is that there's nothing lack
onto him.
>> Yeah, that makes a lot of sense.
>> Imagine sister, imagine I bring you a
dog, then I bring you a rabbit and I say
this rabbit is a child of the dog. Would
you accept that?
>> Obviously not.
>> No. God is not human being is not a
creation. How human is a children of
God? Doesn't make any sense.
>> Not at all. Yeah.
>> You see, you see, you see when when I'm
breaking down for you. So when the
Christians sometimes to go back to your
question, sometimes the Christian
defeat, do you know why? Because
Christians use emotional arguments, some
emotional arguments because we live in a
different time. So we we we we
side more with some even doesn't have
the proof. Even his argument is not is
not an objective argument. But we side
with him because it's emotional and
because we've been in we've been
affected by liberalism
and western uh uh culture.
>> African culture getting married at the
young age is not a problem but in the
western culture is a big problem. But
again like I said to your sister in the
western culture you're not allowed to
get married at the age of young age but
you're allowed to have sex outside
marriage do as much as you like
which contradiction.
>> Yeah that's right. See, see, so Islam
teach us that if you love a woman, get
married to her, you know. And uh again,
now we live in a time is very strange
because some people now even at the age
of 65, they still play PlayStation 2 or
three or five, I don't know.
>> In the western world, a woman, she's 55,
she doesn't know how to cook, but she
knows how to play PlayStation.
Yeah, makes sense. Yeah.
>> So, Subhan Allah. That's why look in
Australia, you have this far right or
these races having a problem with
immigrants. But why immigrants? You
know, if if the immigrants, if us we
leave the western world, the western
world will collapse because the western
world, they don't have young people
anymore. They don't get married anymore.
So, they are in need of us to be here.
Yeah. You see the the economy is based
upon us cuz there's a lot a lot of young
people in Belgium. It's rare. In Britain
as well, they don't get married.
In America, same. They don't get
married. in in France.
That's why Islam pays great attention to
families,
you know, to protect your wife, protect
the husband, protect the children, to
have a healthy and a good society.
Now, majority of crimes in the UK is
been carried out by young people who
comes from broken houses.
>> Mhm. Cuz you have no your no man's
figure, not a father at home or the
mother is not there. Because when a man
sleep with a woman and they're not
married, he knows she cannot take him to
court because he knows by law she has no
right over him.
So he can do whatever he wishes. He can
sleep and run away.
>> But instead comes in if you really love
this woman, get married to her. Now if
I'm married to her, then she's she has a
right over you.
Yeah.
>> You see, and and a lot of young people
now, they want to be young and they want
to run away from responsibilities.
>> But the outcome of this is very
dangerous because what we're going to
do? We're going to there will be no
there will be no next generation
basically cuz people don't want to get
married. And we're going to what we're
going to do, we're going to just start
having children without parents and from
broken houses. And that will cause
children to grow up mentally not well.
I'm talking generally speaking, I'm not
saying every person comes from broken
houses must have mental problems. No,
there are some of them good people. But
generally speaking, when you come from
broken houses or you born out of
fornication, a lot of times you mentally
not stable. You have no father. Your
father run away. Your mother has no one.
You know, we can see that. I mean, we
live in the western world. I mean, we
live in the west. We can see it.
>> Yeah. Yep.
>> Make sense.
>> Makes sense. Yeah.
>> Yeah. You know,
>> so you have another questions.
>> Uh
>> you as you asked something else about
Prophet Muhammad, you said about the age
of marriage. What was the other one you
said?
>> Uh so I was going to ask about the sex.
You know how Salafi the sect itself,
they're always arguing about what's
right and what's not. And of which since
I'm not that knowledgeable yet and I
don't really know any Arabic to read the
Quran is it advisable for me to just
read it in English?
>> Yeah, no problem. You can read in
English but of course
in Arabic you can read the Quran
prophetic sunnah likewise read the work
of the scholars. I mean now English is
the language of science.
Now to physics, biology to physic,
biology, cosmology, majority of uh
research in English. So someone that
loves physics, study physics, study
biology, study this and that, they will
learn English. What about learn about
the the word of God, want to you want to
know what really God said. So you know
the language we got sent down in the in
the language of Arabic language.
You understand?
>> And of course alhamdulillah like I said
to you sister mean to follow the way of
the Quran and the prophetic sunnah
according to disciples of the prophet
Muhammad which is the authentic Islam is
a copism Islam. And of course you you
mentioned about killing or fighting.
I uh I think you already answered.
>> Yeah, that was the one.
>> So now let me ask you a question.
>> Yeah.
>> Be honest to yourself, okay? You know,
>> yeah,
>> nothing is guaranteed in this life
except death. Okay. How many pe people
left the houses, they never come back?
How many people went sleep they never
wake up? How many people had wishes and
they never made it? Prophet Muhammadat
wasam once he draw a circle
then he drew a line which which is
cross over the circle and he said the
circle is the human life and the line
which goes outside from one side starts
outside the circle like this start
outside the circle and it goes over the
circle and out to the other side. He
said this is the human wishes
and what he wants and his desires. So
our desires is longer than our life. And
the prophet Muhammad wasallam said keep
the remembering of
that destroyer of desires.
This life that we are too busy with
sooner or later we're going to live it.
Leave it. and our loved ones, our
mothers and our fathers who loves us so
much, they will put us in the graves by
ourselves and they will leave us alone.
You're going to stand before the creator
by yourself and God will ask you, God,
Allah is the most just. Allah will never
punish people who never knew about the
truth, but Allah will punish those who
recognize the truth and turn away from
him and follow his enemy, Satan. But the
question is,
imagine you die. May Allah forbid, but
you never know. Imagine you die today
and you stand before the almighty God
and he say to you, how come Islam was
clear to you and it made sense to you?
Why did you not accept it? Like now what
is your excuse? What excuse you think
you can think of that you think will be
valid before Allah the Almighty to not
punish you if you don't accept the truth
today.
>> No excuses at all.
>> Excuses
>> we should all be following God.
>> That's it. You know the there is a
narration every human they have two
things. They have
encouragement from the angel and
encouragement from Shayan. So when you
want to accept the truth, the angel will
is push you to to the truth. But you
have a shan also will try to push you to
to the to to to keep you firm upon a
falsehood. So now you have to choose.
You want to follow God's teaching. We
want to follow Shan. That's why in the
Quran Allah said
we showed him the truth and the the the
path of truth. Either he's a believer or
a non-believer. Allah gave you free
will. So I will I will invite you to
accept Islam and to become a Muslim and
to worship Allah correctly because you
know that you are your the Bible has
been corrupted. So how you going to be
worshiping God based upon a corrupted
scripture? You know that doesn't make
any sense. Now you have to preserve
scripture which to worship Allah
according to what he wants you. And when
you become Muslim, you get double reward
as a Christian for being believer in
Jesus. Now accepted Islam and believe in
Prophet Muhammad. So when you become a
Muslim, you're going to believe in Jesus
the way Jesus want you to believe in
him, not Paul or the Roman pagans or the
pagans scribes. Okay? Except in Islam,
you're not going to lose Jesus. You're
going to win Jesus and win prophet
Muhammadatam.
And to give you why Prophet Muhammad was
not a liar was a truthful person.
Prophet Muhammadatam
during his lifetime eclipse happened
and subhan Allah when eclipse happened
the same time at the same day when his
son passed away.
Okay,
>> you with me?
>> Yeah. Yes. So, so his disciples were not
familiar with eclipse. Okay. His
disciples were not familiar with
eclipse. So, they thought the reason
there's eclipse because prophet
Muhammad's son passed away. So, they
start saying, "Ah, there's eclipse. Look
what Allah did because Prophet Muhammad
son passed away." If he was a liar,
remember a liar, dishonest person, he
would try to utilize anything to justify
why he's a true prophet. Correct.
>> Yeah, that's right.
>> Yes. Prophet Muhammad, what he said? He
said, "No, what is happening? Eclipse
have nothing to do with no one's life,
no one's death." This from God. He never
connect them to himself. He connect them
to God. He said when you see it, go and
pray to God.
Again, compare this to what Christopher
Columbus did to the native Americans.
When Christopher Columbus went to
America and the native Americans were
not familiar with eclipse, he told them
the reason there is eclipse because the
god of the Christians are not happy with
you. So give us your belongings. So
Christopher Columbus, he misuse and
utilize the people's ignorance to
manipulate them.
But prophet Muhammad never did this
because he was a truthful person.
Likewise during the life of the prophet
Muhammad wasallam his friend he loved
his wife. So but his wife she wanted to
get divorce from her husband who was the
happened to be the friend of the prophet
Muhammad wasallam. So and she she was a
believer in the messenger of Allah
Muhammad.
So prophet Muhammad wasallam once was
sitting down with his friends and he saw
his friend following his ex-wife. So
Prophet Muhammad went to her and he told
her why don't you go back to him? She
said oh messenger of Allah are you
commanding me because you are the
messenger of Allah or you are just
trying to help. If he was a liar, he
would have what did he would have
utilized his his prophethood because he
claimed to be a prophet of God and he
was a liar by saying to her, "Yes, God
told me you should go back to him." But
what he said, "No, I'm just trying to
help. It's up to you if you want to go
back or you want to leave him
>> again." There's no character.
>> Yeah, definitely. You with me?
Alhamdulillah.
So, and there's many many events.
Example, in the Quran, Prophet Muhammad
never named a chapter of Quran after his
own mother. But there's a chapter of
Quran named after the mother of Jesus.
Oh,
>> or chapter of Mary, Miam.
There's no chapter of the in the Quran
named after the tribe of the prophet
Muhammad. But there's there's a chapter
in the Quran named after the tribe of
Ali Imran who are Israelites.
>> Yeah, that says a lot.
>> Subhan Allah. Because if I'm a liar and
again if Prophet Muhammad was a liar, he
would have said my mother, his mother
and his father are in paradise. But
guess what he said? He said no because
they were pagans. They go to hellfire.
to show you he was conveying what God
told him.
>> If I'm a liar, I'm gonna say, you know
what? You know that if he was a liar,
his uncle that took care of him, he said
he will go to hellfire because he never
believed in God correctly. If he was a
liar, how come in Medina? You know
Medina,
you know this?
>> I haven't heard of it. No, I'm still new
to this. That's why.
>> Yes. Medina. Mecca. Prophet Muhammad was
born in Mecca. Then he migrated to
Medina. This where he lived and he had
followers and he died. Yeah. In Mecca
there was Israelites. Lot of Jewish
people in Mecca. And they those Jewish
people the Arab pagans used to respect
them because they were people of the
book that scripture.
If Prophet Muhammad was a liar,
he would have agreed with the Jewish
people in Medina in terms of or regarded
Jesus to be a false messiah. But what he
said, he said, "No, Jesus was a true
messiah and his mother was a righteous
woman."
>> And remember, when someone is a liar,
he's going to declare to you prophet of
God either because he wants money or he
wants leadership. But when he studied
the biography of Prophet Muhammad, even
though he conquered places, he never
took money. He was a poor person. Okay?
And there's a story when
someone came tried to kill him and
prophet Muhammad Allah protected him.
Then prophet Muhammad had a sword. He
said, "You want me to kill you?" The
person said, "Oh messenger, oh Muhammad,
you are a generous son of generous."
Prophet Muhammad left him let him go
free and he gave him a lot of of goats
animals
>> to show his generous. So clearly prophet
Muhammad is a true prophet and our Islam
goes allow intellect. So I would invite
you sister to become Muslim
openly and that will be good for you
inshallah.
Ready?
Yes stop you. How old?
>> How about
>> Oh, I'm 21.
>> Come on. My wife My wife was 14. She
become Muslim.
>> That's right.
>> Go on. You always going to ask question.
>> Yeah. Yeah. How about uh you know how
with women we're I mean they're supposed
to cover up
>> Yeah.
>> all the way. Whereas with men they don't
really have to cover up that much.
>> So I was just wondering
>> Yeah. How do you how do you even accept
um
you know the fact that I'm I have to
wear this even in summer it gets pretty
hot especially with the nikabi.
>> No no it doesn't you know I mean like of
course I'm not a woman but you know
firstly if you're from Zimbabwe correct
>> that's right yeah
>> in in a hot countries did you know that
they wear more clothes in in summer?
M
>> go I'll tell you to advise you to to
believe me go and put in YouTube desert
and see how they dress they cover their
face they cover their heads why to
protect themselves from the the the sun
okay and now when you come to and the
material is not that thick it's not
thick also it's a test I mean Mary she
she covered herself and in the Bible in
the Bible also God told you to cover
self.
>> Yeah,
>> of course. Understand? Mary, she she
dress like the Muslim. So when Allah
told you to cover yourself, of course,
it's going to be test for you. But it's
for your own sake, for your own good.
But we men likewise, we have to cover
ourselves. But of course, Allah created
men and women differently. Like for
example, in the summer time, you don't
have to go outside in a sun heat and go
pray to the mosque in the mosque.
But I have excuse the mosque.
>> Oh yeah, that's right.
>> So in if there's war in Islam, you don't
have to go outside and fight, but I have
to go and fight.
>> Yeah. That's your role as a man in
when the summer time is hot. If I have
to go out and provide for you, you don't
have to go out and provide for for your
husband.
>> Yep. That's right. You see, so
alhamdulillah Allah is the most just
when Allah told a woman to cover
herself. Of course, in a summer there's
material which is a material which is
not like a like a I mean a woman is
allowed to wear sik. I'm not aware to
wear sik. You're allowed to wear gold.
I'm not allowed to wear gold. If you
want to start complaining, we men have
many things. You understand? But we know
whatever Allah legis did for us is good
for us. However, Allah will test us and
this life is a test. Allah will test us
with ease, likewise with hardship like
he tested and try those who came before
us.
But what I say to you sister, don't let
nothing to divert you from accepting
Islam cuz Satan will try to do
everything to divert you from worshiping
your God. Let me give you example.
Imagine you are in your own room and out
of nowhere fire starts in your own room
and there's fire everywhere and you try
your best to save yourself and you
couldn't and you gave up and I came and
I saved your life. What would you say to
me at least?
>> Thank you for sure.
>> Would you remember me all the time for
saving your life?
>> Yeah, definitely.
>> Of course. So why why don't you why you
not grateful and thankful to God who
gave your life for free?
>> Good point.
>> Yes. Now you say I want to be grateful.
I want to worship God. The second
question imagine you want to buy a gift
for your mother. Would you buy a gift
that you love or your mother love?
>> Yeah my mother loves. Likewise, if you
want to be grateful to create to your
creator, worship your creator, then you
do it the way he loves, not the way we
love. Because the way he loves is
objective. The way we love is
subjective. That's the the in summary
the meaning of when you say I bear
witness. There's no one worthy of
worship except Allah mean I want to
worship Allah. I want to be grateful to
him. I want to appreciate him. and
Muhammad the messenger of Allah mean I
want to worship Allah according to his
teaching which is the true prophet
Muhammad
you know even though you don't know who
I am I can be someone that do evil
things but because I saved something so
dear to you said I will thank you
straight away so what about God who gave
you life give you eyes give you oxygen
you breathe in out for free your eyes is
for free you know you gain everything
for free and Allah said if to try to
count Allah blessings, you will never be
able to do so. So why you hesitating to
become a Muslim and accept your creator
and worship Allah the way he wants to be
uh to worship him alone.
Don't let nothing stop you. And you know
what I'm encouraging you to become
Muslim because I want the reward as
well.
You see, I don't want no money from you.
Don't even thank me. I don't I want a
reward cuz the reward you becoming
Muslim and woriing the creator is a big
reward. It's better than money,
Lamborghini, Ferrari, you name it.
>> Yeah.
>> You see what I'm saying?
>> Yeah. Very much eye opening. It all
makes sense. It really does.
Alhamdulillah.
Alhamdulillah. You accept Islam then now
even but Allah forbid even if you die
all your sins all your sins forgiven and
you enter paradise. But of course when
you become Muslim Allah will test you.
Allah said
Allah said to the people who think they
will say or believe and Allah will not
test them. Allah will test them like he
tested those who came before them in
order for Allah to see who is a truthful
and who is a liar. So what I would say
to you sister, if the Islam is clear to
you, the truth is clear to you, don't
let nothing stop you. That's my advice
to you. Don't lie. Don't let nothing.
>> Who who was speaking to you before? Is
that your family or friend?
>> Oh, it's just a friend.
>> Muslim.
>> Yeah, she's Muslim.
>> She wants to become Muslim. See? So,
alhamdulillah. Alhamdulillah. So, if
you're ready, Alhamdulillah. And I don't
want to put no pressure on you sister,
but I know I've I've been doing this
since like for over a decade. And you
know what, sister? When the people
accept Islam, I have never seen someone
going accept Islam. They come back says,
you know, Shamsi, I regret accept Islam.
They always say to me, I wish I accept
Islam earlier.
>> I've heard that too. A lot of
testimonies. You see, alhamdulillah, you
see this sign from God, you know,
who is more unjust than the one who
Allah's
and he turns away from it
or truly will take our revenge. And the
great crime sister against God will turn
away from him or you worship him
according to your desires. You
understand? So alhamdulillah now you can
accept Islam and worship God and be a
servant of Allah and believe in God and
your all your sins forgiven.
Alhamdulillah.
>> Amen to that. Uh one last question. Um
how do you overcome the temptations?
Because in Christianity, we're taught to
believe that whenever you pray about it,
uh God answers your prayers and of
course your life gets better. Um so with
Islam, how do you pray about it? How do
you learn the prayers the five times a
day?
>> First,
>> you know, facing
firstly uh of course, alhamdulillah, how
to deal with temptations and tell us how
to deal with it.
Not just prayer, also there's other
tools that you can utilize. Okay,
>> prayer is important. Of course, you're
asking God to help you. You know, but
Allah said in the Quran,
Allah will never change state of people
until they change themselves. So I pray,
oh God, I don't want to drink alcohol,
but I'm thinking tomorrow I'm going to
go drink alcohol. You have to start with
yourself as well. You have to have that
zeenness and motivation to not do it
again. To stay away from it also to stay
away from the places where there's a lot
of temptations.
>> You understand? So in the Quran Allah
said
do not come closer to fornication. No do
not fornicate. So do not even come
closer to it.
So understand the prayer you learn. Of
course they will pray five times a day.
Even about the prayer in Islam, we pray
like Jesus pro straight bound down like
Moses. So Islam there's two tough
prayer. There's a prayer which requires
for you to do abolution and there's a
prayer and after you do abolution you
just raise your hand and you pray. Okay.
So
>> alhamdulillah we have videos teaching
how to pray. But when you understand the
greatness of Allah and we Muslims we
worship Allah based upon three things.
based upon love. We love Allah. That's
why we worship him. Likewise, we fear
Allah. Likewise, we hope that Allah will
forgive us and enter us paradise.
So, the way to help you to understand
that Allah is all Noah. Allah is the
greatest and Allah sees everything.
Allah hears everything and you read the
Quran, you listen to to to lectures and
you understand your heart. Prophet
Muhammad wasallam said there is a piece
of flesh within the body. If it is good
the whole body will be good and if it's
corrupted the whole body was be
corrupted and that is the the heart.
You have to purify yourself. There's two
type of of purification Islam. Purity of
the heart and purification of the body.
How to purify your heart? from
arrogance,
from loving this world more than the
hereafter, more than paradise, from
loving Satan more than God, or
preferring
or uh favoring Satan and his allies over
God. And by way of doing this is by
staying away from the evil and Satan and
reading the Quran and follow God's
teaching and have a strong belief. And
to have strong belief requires you to
have correct knowledge.
>> Look,
watch this system.
>> Look, I have too many books about the
heart which is based upon the Quranic
teaching.
>> Look.
The
>> the heart of the hearts.
>> Yeah.
>> Also I have this
>> winning the war within. All right.
>> The hearts the self and just the devils
and so I have alhamdulillah have many
books about the hearts. Look have this
book as well.
>> Yep. Having good thoughts of Allah.
>> Yeah. So this book about you know also
we're not perfect. All of us have our
own struggles and our mistakes. In Islam
we have the concept of forgiveness. If
you fall into sin you repent to Allah
and try your best to not go back to it.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I've just started reading
what's it called?
This is Islam
the book.
>> Abu. Yeah. That's a nice book. Very nice
book.
>> Is that a good one? Okay. No worries.
>> Good one. You know what I've been saying
to you is from that book.
>> Oh,
>> so I have some.
>> Yo, do I even need to read it now?
>> No, summarize it. I mean, you should
still read it.
>> Yeah. But what I will say to you,
sister, you should become Muslim.
Alhamdulillah. It makes sense to you.
It's clear.
Alhamdulillah. You make yourself happy
and you're going to make your friend
happy and you're going to Allah be happy
with you as well. Imagine the one who's
not in need of you is going to be happy
that you turn back to him.
>> And he's not in need of you. He's not in
need of me. But Allah read
Allah wants good for us, easy for us.
And harshness and hardship will turn
away from God.
So like I say always I always emphasize
do you believe is is the truth make
sense to you? Is it clear to you? If you
say yes alhamdulillah you know if you
love your mother with your heart would
you not say it?
>> Yes I would.
>> Would you not do it through your actions
by taking care of her. So if you believe
is a truth and it makes sense then
profess it. And remember Shayan your
enemy is devil that with with every
human with every one of us the devil's
devil is trying to do everything to stop
you like I said either you want to
choose the path of God or the path of
Satan becoming a Muslim mean submit
yourself to God according to God's
teaching you're going to be making God
happy with you even though he's not in
need of you but if you turn away Satan
is going to be happy with you and so if
If you believe in God and become Muslim,
you're going to displease Satan, our
enemy. You understand? But Muhammad
wasallam said whenever someone wants to
become Muslim, Satan will bring a doubt.
How you going to become Muslim? Your
family Christian, your family Hindu,
Buddhist, how you going to do this? It's
too much. This and that. But all of this
is not going to benefit you.
>> You understand?
>> Yeah.
>> Alhamdulillah. Ready?
>> Alhamdulillah.
>> That's it.
Alhamdulillah.
>> Amen. No worries at all. Yeah.
>> You want to speak a Muslim now?
>> Yes. I'm a Muslim.
>> I said Arabic. I say sh Arabic then
repeated English. Okay. Say after me au
Allah.
>> Allah.
illah
Allah
>> were ashu
ashu
>> Allah
>> Muhamadan
>> rasool
>> Allah
>> Isa
>> Asa
>> Abdullah
>> Abdullah Abdullah
>> in English I bear witness
>> I bear witness
>> there is nothing
>> worthy of worship
>> in truth
>> except Allah
>> and and I bear witness
>> and I bear witness
>> that Muhammad
by Muhammad.
>> That's Muhammad
>> as Muhammad.
>> That that that's Muhammad.
>> That's Muhammad. Yeah.
>> Is the last messenger
>> is the last messenger
>> and the servant of Allah
>> and a servant of Allah. And that Jesus
>> And that Jesus
>> is the servant
>> and the messenger of Allah.
>> And the messenger of Allah.
>> Alhamdulillah. My sister, you are
obviously Muslim. I'm very happy for
you. You by Allah Allah's permission you
I'm very happy. You made my night cuz we
are tonight. We are night. You are day
in Australia.
>> Yes.
and my sister, may Allah keep you firm.
I'm very very happy for you. I'm very
happy for you. And this type of
discussions and dialogue that motivate
me to go more on Tik Tok live and go
speak and keep giving dawa to people
because I know there's many people like
you who are sincerely seeking the truth,
who are honest, who are not arrogant,
very humble. Alhamdulillah that Allah
guided you to Islam. You are revert.
You're going back into your original
state. Alhamdulillah.
Amen.
>> Allah bless you my sister and inshallah
you know before I was just saying sister
now I will say my sister.
>> Yes. Amen.
>> Allah bless you and I send myself to the
sister next to you. So do you have any
question or something?
>> Uh
I have another question from a friend.
Yes. Um so it says what? Yeah. What if
someone says they're Salafi and another
person says they're Salafi as well and
they're very different about something
that's complicated?
How do I know which is right? Because to
me I don't understand it with deep
insight and that will leave a doubt
within me.
>> Okay, there's certain things which is if
it's very complicated like the so if
there's different between Muslims, we go
back to Quran and Sunnah. Okay, there
are some issues we should have no
problem with. For example, now Prophet
Muhammad said when you come back from
the prayer from the when you praying and
you come back from bowing down you say
then put your hands the way it starts.
Some scholars said the way you start
means to put your hands like this
because when you start the prayer you go
Allahbar and you put your hands here.
Some scholars said no you start the
prayer when you face Mecca. So you start
while your hands aside. So if you choose
this opinion the other opinion there's
no problem with that and we should not
differ okay
>> because the text is not clear okay and
there's no problem because this occurred
at the time prophet Muhammad where told
him something and Sahabah they differ in
the understanding of the commandments
and proam did not rebuke none of them
however there are certain things which
is clear in the sunnah that if we differ
we have to go back to Quran to the Quran
and the Sunnah and follow what is in the
Quran and Sunnah. Is that clear?
>> Yes, that's clear. Yep.
>> May Allah bless you, my sister. Is your
family Christians or mix?
>> They're all Christian. Yeah.
>> I will ask you be be nice to them. Be
respectful to them. Be good to them. Be
patient with them. But make sure you
learn. Okay. And uh and uh ask to guide
them. You never know. I mean like of
course you can I'm not sure if you watch
my videos but alhamdulillah but Allah
still fear through me many people become
Muslims and this all belongs to Allah
blessings but my wife's mom I've been
trying for a long time and I come she's
not Muslim she wants to become Muslim
but she keep saying tomorrow tomorrow
tomorrow okay sometimes she's changed
but it shows you changing the heart is
in the hand of Allah me I didn't change
your heart I just convey the message But
because you honest and Allah love those
who are honest and sincere. So Allah
guide you to Islam and it's a blessing
that my sister you should be very very
grateful Allah because Allah is not in
need of you. There is million of people
out there and Allah never guide them to
Islam either ignorance or they
arrogance.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. My sister, it's nearly 2:00 in the
morning here. I mean I'm very happy. If
you have any questions, sister, you can
contact us via private message in our
Tik Tok or Instagram. Okay.
>> Yep. No worries at all.
>> All right.
>> No worries. To you, too. Bye.
>> Thank you. You're welcome, my sister.
Bye.
>> Alhamdulillah. What a night.
Alhamdulillah.
A beautiful night. Alhamdulillah.
Allahbar. Allahbar.
Alhamdulillah.
This from Allah.
Allah abar. What a blessing from Allah.
Alhamdulillah. May Allah keep.
May Allah keep a.
So this how you convert someone. Yes.
Yes. This how are you Muslim?
Alhamdulillah.
Anyway, I would love likewise I can see
there's other guests here. I would love
to bring more people but I really have
to go inshallah
and alhamdulillah Allah guided our
sister from Zimbabwe
Zimbabwe
Islam.
Malik just researching now. I mean if
you want to come and and ask questions
because I have no problem to continue
especially when you come to someone
sincerely seeking the truth. If you want
to come and ask questions you're more
than welcome or you want to send us
private message you are more than
welcome. whatever want to do.
But you have like Muslim name.
So sister Malik, you want to come to the
live stream and ask questions? We'll
have conversation.
Okay. Okay. You can send us a private
message uh sister Malik. Anyway, my dear
brothers and sisters, may Allah bless
you all and may Allah guide the
non-Muslims to Islam.
You know this guy.
Allah bless you all my brothers and
sisters.